in the long queues they watched the
television coverage of this historic
event
they're all part of history now
and at the very front of this line are
three ladies who forged a friendship
Vanessa Annie and Grace spent four days
sleeping here and they'll be the first
to see the queen lion State I don't know
what I'm going to be expecting in there
when you walk in we'll be just saying
prayers in my heart for her peaceful
rest and thank Mound for the great
service that she's done for 70 years in
Rain non-stop if I didn't get that
chance to be in the first but I've still
come to Europe anyway
I just think it's we like the ceremonial
aspect of it the guards gleaming buttons
the Polish
you know the regimentation when the
guards come by and just being enthralled
by it and thrilled by it since I was
four if I were to be at the back maybe I
feel I'll feel
tired to go home but because I'm I'm
just here in the front of the queue I
feel so it gave me the Courage the
determination
it is a huge effort directing so many
people into one place
eight-year-old Louis jenkinson from
Oxford told me he's a big fan of the
queen she was a very funny woman
I like the petting Paddington Bear bit
yeah that was cool wasn't it yeah it was
pretty funny yeah well thanks for
talking to me Louie well listen
to the conversation I've had with
them is it yeah I do go on a bit
and this is what they were waiting for
to see with their own eyes to be in the
same room to have their moment with
their Queen
we're waiting you're queuing up for this
moment but the moment you see the coffee
it it is a it hits you and and uh I
don't think you're ever really ready for
that we all came out my daughter my
granddaughter and I came out of you know
quite emotional really to give her our
respect for everything that she's done
70 years of service
I won't find a bit of cream will you
there are now thousands of people
queuing to see the queen lie in state
and this line goes on for Miles young
old some from nearby others have
traveled from far afield but they are
all part of a remarkable people's
pilgrimage
they are Unforgettable images of a
Nation mourning Nick Martin Sky News
Western